i definitely have a sexy side
oh yes she does kim kardashian is
fearless
at 40.
on instagram the reality star was
looking fire showing off her figure in a
tan bikini
rocking large shades and a bandana the
kkw boss lady captioned it
this is 40. it just looks so good and
kim's family and friends were there to
hype her up in the comments
sister kendall jenner responded to the
snap sure is kim's bff jonathan cheban
wrote
40 looks better than 39 and simon huck
said
there it is i feel like this is when
life really
begins and it's been so much fun to be
on this journey
a source tells et that the skim's mogul
is celebrating her milestone birthday
with her family
and close friends we are so blessed to
have the best support system and the
best
family kim got everyone together for the
big event and is looking forward to
celebrating with the ones who mean the
most to her the source adds that the
mama 4
is in a really good place and can't wait
to celebrate
that's what's really important to me
another source tells e.t
that the birthday girl flew everyone out
on private planes to vacay on an island
so beyond excited the reality star
already rang in her 40th
sharing her epic family surprise party
on a special episode of keeping up with
the kardashians
ponies and a balloon what the [ __ ] is
this
as soon as i heard my dad's voice
talking as if it was
my first birthday it all clicked kim
walked down memory lane at the
extravagant event which highlighted all
of her past
birthday parties to see them all set up
as i walk through this
party and then just have it like the
huge screens playing my birthday parties
so fun to see that all come to life they
even got the same white bmw
that kim got as her first car for her
16th birthday
but it wasn't complete without her
sisters recreating a dance number
previously performed at her 10th
[Music]
[Applause]
birthday
you